[Music]
how would you feel if internet trolls
convince the world that you're dead or
if you were sued by your own mother
needless to say the cast of Pawn Stars
have dealt with all brands of tragedy
over the years operating a pawn shop
certainly comes with a hefty dose of
drama as seen in the series some
customers can get extremely heated when
they feel insulted or slanted by an
offer from the Pawn Stars such was the
case back in 2012 when one sore customer
became aggressive towards the staff as
first revealed by the TV show right this
minute Vietnam veteran Daniel Callahan
eventually sued the old man Richard and
Rick Harrison stated that they put him
in a choke hold and threw him out of the
store isn't that excessive while news
and gossip sites quickly began spreading
the story Cory Bigos Harrison eventually
clarified the lawsuit explaining that
his father and grandfather were not to
blame for the violent removal of
Callahan he told the Las Vegas Review
Journal they were never in the room with
him the Harrison son went on to say that
though he didn't witness the incident in
question he would understand the veteran
being thrown out of the store he had
been quote absolutely ired with a weapon
in his hand and 4,000 people waiting and
demanding to see the owner in the end
the Elder Harrison were on the hook
hooked for the $20,000 lawsuit against
the 62-year-old warvet one of the most
entertaining elements of Pawn Stars is a
comprehensive history explained about
individual pieces of memorabilia
learning about how a coin was minted or
the expressive techniques used by
certain artists is what draws Us in and
keeps us invested throughout each
episode and while the cast of Pawn Stars
have no problem admitting when they
don't know something it will dutifully
call in an expert it seems as if they
all have a wealth of knowledge about
history and politics especially Rick
Harrison who seemingly knows something
about pretty much everything well it's
been revealed that pawn star as scripted
we don't blame anyone for scoffing at
such a statement but that tidbit aside
it still goes without saying that Rick
has a lot of experience in the business
and has picked up a lot of knowledge
along the way what a lot of fans might
not know is that he never completed high
school as such the Central Pawn Star is
much more of an entrepreneur than a
student after dropping out Harrison
started a lucrative business selling
knockoff luxury bags with a natural
Savvy Harrison was able to go into
business alongside his father and the
pair jointly built the Gold and Silver
Pawn Shop from the ground up Austin
Russell better known as Chumley is the
standout fan favorite cast member of
Pawn Stars thanks to his delightful
bantering with the Harrison family
starting in the series as a comic foil
or more accurately The Village Idiot
Chumley has grown to become an expert
negotiator himself often dealing in
sneakers and collectibles additionally
Russell has become quite the
entrepreneur himself opening his own
popular candy store across the street
from gold and silver in Las Vegas sadly
it hasn't all been smooth sailing for
Chumley the resident jokester a Pawn
Stars tragically lost his father weeks
before his hit series debuted on History
beyond that in 2016 the reality icon got
in hot water with the authorities
resulting in some serious charges
investigating an unsubstantiated sexual
assault charge police raided the reality
star's home and uncovered a Ford of
drugs and a gun pleading guilty in court
Russell narrowly avoided jail time and
was instead sentenced to 3 years of
Probation and counseling although the
staff and management may be the icons of
Pawn Stars there's an assortment of
recurring guests that fans of the series
have grown to love the experts called in
to make assessments on some of the most
glorious prizes to enter the Gold and
Silver Pawn Shop the calvary specialist
and the Harrison vintage Rolodex has
heaps of expertise in unique Fields
experts like antiquarians Mark Hall
Patton and Rebecca Romney have become
fan favorite characters on the reality
series meanwhile appraisers like Rick
Dale and Danny Coker became so popular
that they earned their own spin-off
shows however there is one expert who
hasn't popped up on the series for some
time and for a reason you might not
expect Johnny Jimenez Jr was one of the
pawn star's regular Consultants when it
came to vintage toys the professional
toy store owner helped Chumley and the
Harrison come to terms on a number of
deals throughout the years while many of
fans do not know is that Jimenez was
arrested in 2015 for allegedly knocking
his girlfriend to the ground according
to TMZ video surveillance showed the toy
shop owner pulling his extremely
intoxicated partner to the ground by her
purse strap when police arrived jenez
told them that he was trying to get her
inside the restaurant to eat because she
was drunk while his girlfriend remained
unresponsive for several minutes jenz
claimed that he never intended for her
to be knocked over him menis told ktnv
I'm really disappointed that the police
here could not get the facts before they
put someone in handcuffs although he may
be the world's greatest negotiator when
it comes to Priceless pieces of Arts or
forgotten relics of the past Rick
Harrison hasn't been as fortunate when
it comes to relationships the spotter of
the Gold and Silver Pawn Shop has had
multiple marriages resulting in several
children notably his co-star Cory Bigos
Harrison and his brother Adam were born
to Rick's first wife Kim in his second
marriage Rick welcomed his third son
jack Harrison by far Rick Harrison's
most public marriage was to Dianna burn
it the parti the not in 2013 with
counting Carr's host Danny Coker
officiating the ceremony and Chumley
serving as the ring bearer sadly the
pair quietly and mutually separated
about 7 years later in 2020 perhaps
unsurprisingly the pawn star did not
remain single for long as he married his
fourth wife Amanda Palmer in 2021 while
he's always been one of the most
entertaining facets of Pawn Stars
Chumley has been the center of many
rumors throughout the years most
prominently back in 2014 fans were
briefly in mourning when the reality
television personality was the victim of
a death hoax astute fans will notice how
much Chum's weight can fluctuate from
season to season the pawning sidekick
tried to lose a lot of weight around
2013 tell me in the Las Vegas Review
Journal I'm going to the gym 6 days a
week I'm eating right well balanced diet
I drink a juice smoothie every morning
I'm making sure I'm eating my vegetables
and staying away from the red meat given
that his father died of pancreatic
cancer at 54 it's understandable that
Chum is worried about his health
unfortunately the abrupt change in
weight resulted in a hoax that Chumley
suffered fatal heart problems the
comedic personality took to a Formerly
Known his Twitter to relieve his
saddened fans saying may we live long
Rich Forever in more recent years
Chumley underwent gas RCT sleeve surgery
helping him to lose over 160 lb well
done sir Bravo for most of the 21
seasons of Pawn Stars there have been
only a handful of main cast members
typically limited to the Harrison family
and Chumley however devout fans of the
series will recall a brief period back
in 2012 when the boys were joined by a
female regular Olivia Black fans quickly
took a liking to her as did onscreen
personalities Cory and Chumley sadly
black only remained with the series for
13 episodes leaving many wondering what
happened to the pawn shop employee
shockingly it was later revealed that
black was canned from the series after
nude photos of her surfaced from her
time before joining the series
reportedly the former model was only
fired from appearing on the show and
Rick Harrison had no intention of
letting her go he told Fox News I never
fired her she's out doing her own thing
now it's just the production company did
not want her working there anymore what
she does in her personal life is her
business regardless black was advised to
fire back by filing a lawsuit against a
production company left field pictures
and an online petition called for her to
be rehired however she eventually left
the shop of her own accord and returned
to her modeling career and has done
quite well since likely thanks in part
to her temporary reality Fame it's hard
to guess whether Pawn Stars would have
ever been as successful without his most
disgruntled cast member Richard Oldman
Harrison co-owner and operator of the
world famous Gold and Silver Pawn Shop
the old man is recognized as the man who
started the family business throughout
the series his bitter attitude
especially towards Chumley created some
of the show's most laughable moments
additionally the old man was at times
the most Harden negotiator of the whole
crew tragically Pawn Stars has not been
the same since 2018 after Richard
Harrison passed away it's not going to
be the same it's not going to be the
same without the old man being there the
Navy veteran is understandably missed by
his family friends and fans resulting in
a special episode of Pawn Stars titled a
treasure remembered which featured
highlights and interviews about the
longtime reality television personality
still nothing may be as touching as a
social media post from his son Rick
Harrison he wrote on Instagram today I
lost a friend a father a teacher and so
much more the old man lost his long
battle with Parkinson's this morning
love you Dad see you on the side on top
of the tragedy of Richard Harrison's
death that ended up causing some drama
behind the scenes survived by three sons
the old man shockingly opted to Omit one
of his children from his will while Rick
Harrison was left in charge of his
father and pawn star's co-star's estate
the remainder of his fortune was passed
on to a surviving wife and third child
leaving one child without a scent court
records obtained by celebrity gossip
website the blast show that the
surprising Omission came in 2017 a short
time before the Elder Harrison's passing
in the update to his will Harrison
allegedly expressed his love for his son
Christopher but cut him out of the will
regardless Christopher might be unknown
to some fans since he has never appeared
on Pawn Stars there is no explanation
why Christopher Harrison was
purposefully left out of the will
however it did not seem to come as a
shock to the Harrison Rick Harrison told
the Las Vegas Review Journal the family
had previously discussed this
information and it is A Private Matter
unfortunately the Harrison family drama
only worsened after everything was said
and done with Richard Oldman Harrison's
estate in the aftermath Rick Harrison
was sued by his aging mother who said
that he was in breach of contract
regarding the state of his father's
finances Joanne Harrison was married to
the old man for 58 years and when the
Elder Harrison passed away she alleged
that she inherited a 49% share of the
pawn shop however in her 2022 lawsuit
Joanne claimed that her son had
inadequately provided her with
documentation of the store's finances
worse she alleged that Rick tricked her
into signing over her 51% share of the
company after she was hospitalized years
prior additionally she alleged that over
$500,000 of old man Harrison's estate
had gone unaccounted for while the
matter is ongoing Rick Harrison has
denied any wrong doing he told the Las
Vegas Review Journal the allegations are
false I think that my 81-year-old mother
is being manipulated by others for their
personal gain still less than a month
later Joanne Harrison filed for a
temporary restraining order against her
celebrity son the world famous Gold and
Silver Pawn Shop has always been a
family business and even with Richard
Harrison passing away the family still
operates the storefront while continuing
to film new episodes of Pawn Stars
maintaining the fatherson connection
Cory Bigos Harrison loyally maintains
his position beside his father making
deals and buying treasur unfortunately
Cory has had his share of tribulations
alongside the rest of the pawn star's
cast The Young Harrison has been through
a pair of divorces himself most recently
from his second wife Karina Harrison in
2018 beyond that the reality television
star got into trouble with the law in
September 2023 when he was arrested for
driving under the influence of alcohol
in Las Vegas he was pulled over after
being seen swerving his vehicle between
lanes and the pawn star failed to field
sobriety test and was taken into custody
Arison told the Las Vegas Review Journal
a suck at playing Simon says you're
obviously nervous every time you get
pulled over it's not a normal thing for
me it's stand on this leg stand on that
leg walk in a straight line 2024 hasn't
been kind to the Harrison family so far
Adam Harrison son of Rick Harrison sadly
passed away in January as a result of a
fentanyl overdose at the age of 39
brother to Cory Harrison Adam never
shared his family's ambition to be on
television although he reportedly worked
at the pawn shop for some time before
becoming a plumber lovingly given the
nickname wax Adam's death understandably
hit the Harrison family hard a statement
from the Harrison's read our family is
extremely saddened by the death of Adam
we ask for privacy as we Grievous loss
meanwhile the family took to Instagram
to share their heartbreak Rick Harrison
wrote you will always be in my heart I
love you Adam Cory also took the
Instagram and shared a picture of him
and his brother as children Rick told
TMZ on January 22nd 2024 the fentanyl
crisis in this country must be taken
more seriously what's in this vial is 2
mg that is a potentially lethal dose of
fenel if you or anyone you know needs
help with addiction issues help is
available visit the Substance Abuse and
Mental Health Services Administration
website or contact samsa's National
helpl line at 1 1800 662 heal